if you're running around now trying to
get out the door you are not alone
nearly half of americans say they don't
have enough time to do what they want to
do cassie holmes may be able to help
though she studies the connection
between time and our overall happiness
and satisfaction her new book is happier
hour how to beat distraction expand your
time and focus on what matters most it
is published by gallery books an imprint
of simon institute which is like cbs
owned by paramount global cassie good
morning good morning dr cassie i should
say your phd you study this and you
found that there that if you have two to
five hours of free time a day
you can be fulfilled and happy what is
that sweet spot
yeah and it's an important thing to
recognize because as you noted we run
around and we feel so
much like we don't have enough time and
in those moments we're like if only i
had more hours in the day than i would
be happier and we tested this and what
we found was yes
folks with too little time are indeed
less happy because they're more stressed
but the thing we didn't expect was that
when folks have too much time they're
also less happy because that surprised
me yeah and it's because when we spend
you know all of the hours of a regular
day with nothing to show for it we don't
feel productive
and that undermines our sense of purpose
and from that we feel dissatisfied and
so
what our research is suggesting it's not
about being time rich it's about making
the time that you have rich and that's
the sort of next step in the process of
identifying for oneself what are those
ways of spending time that feel really
worthwhile so that you can dedicate more
time to those hours or those activities
and less time to
a lot of the activities that fill our
days that feel more wasteful but do we
lie to ourselves about the time that do
we say i don't have any time i can't do
it i can't write a book i can't you know
learn a new skill like it's an exercise
status thing where people want to
project busyness out into the world
right i suggest that they're so
important but even presidents go to the
gym and they take time i mean
are we kidding ourselves sometimes we do
have the hours in the day to spend on
these activities that not only are
worthwhile but they themselves are happy
and they translate to make the other
activities that we do happier and
make us feel better while doing them so
there are these mood boosts and the way
to identify that is through time
tracking to identify okay how am i
spending my time and more important than
that how am i feeling how does doing
that activity make me feel you actually
say we should write it down you you said
that happiness is a choice we all have
the same 24 hours in a day but your
research has determined there are
basically three factors that determine
happiness
yes one two three yeah so our
personality does have an impact on how
we feel but that is outside of our
control you know i'm lucky enough to
sort of be a naturally happy person they
called you little miss happiness when
you
but we're all subjected to life
circumstances
and those circumstances do have an
effect on how we feel and that you know
the last couple years these are
circumstances that haven't been so
positive but interestingly
those circumstances don't have as much
of an effect as we think they do the
thing that has the effect that we have
control over is how we spend our time
and how we think about the time and
being
not distracted while we're spending it
so that when you are spending on your
time on those really worthwhile
activities you
are paying attention so you get to feel
the happiness from it
um and there is a lot of
joy right there in our day-to-day and
it's a question of not missing out on it
you call your research me search because
it's stuff that you want to work for you
and i can see it is working so i think
that's for other people as well cassie
homes it's so great to have you this
book's incredible thank you very very
much for being here happy hour hour is
out today pick it up this is cbs
mornings we'll be right back